[موسيقى]
هذه الهوايه كانت منذ السفر اكثر من 35
سنه وانا اجمع في هذه الاشياء بدات حقيقه
في عملات السعوديه
المعدنيه سواء في عهد الملك سعود او في
عهد الملك فيصل ومن ثم بدات اطور نفسي
وابدا اجمع العملات اللي هي محيطه بالدول
اللي كانت محيطه بالمملكه العربيه
السعوديه وبعد ما بدانا نتعمق في هذه
الاشياء صرت اجمع
العملات اللي كانت تتداول في العصر
الاسلامي من بدايه عهد الرسول اللهم صل
وسلم عليه الى العهد الاموي والعباسي ومن
ثم بقيه الدول الى العصر العثماني
[موسيقى]
جميع الاشياء اللي انا اقتنيتها من عملات
او تراث اسلامي او اشياء اسلاميه كلها
طبعا كانت لها قصص تاريخيه بالنسبه لي في
منها صعب وفي منها سهل علشان انا اتحصل
على قطعه اسلاميه مثلا عمله اسلاميه تهمني
كنت اسافر الى اوروبا سافر الى مناطق
بعيده اسافر الى اليمن للحصول على هذه
الاشياء واشترك في مزادات عالميه للحصول
على هذه الاشياء وكانت تكاليفها عاليه جدا
ليست بالسهل
ومن اصعب الامور التي انا واجهتها عندما
زرت اليمن لاقتناء مجموعه من المجموعه من
العملات الاسلاميه التي ضربت في جنوب
الجزيره العربيه او في جنوب المملكه اللي
هي الدنانير العباسيه التي ضربت في منطقه
بيش واثر
[موسيقى]
طبعا المتحف يحتوي كما هو مسمى متحف
الدينار الاسلامي يحتوي على جميع الاشياء
الاسلاميه الخاصه بنا كمسلمين المتعب
يحتوي على مجموعه كبيره من المخطوطات
الاسلاميه يبلغ عددها ما يزيد على 360
مخطوط تتكلم في الفقه والحديث والتفسير
والطب والرياضيات بالاضافه الى مجموعه
كبيره من الاسلحه من السيوف الاسلاميه
لها اكثر من مئات السنين كذلك بعض الاشياء
اللي هي مثلا الخناجر
والاشياء الاسلاميه مثلا الخزفيات
والفخاريات والنحاسيات من عصور اسلاميه من
العهد الامويه العصر العباسي الى تقريبا
العثماني كذلك يوجد مجموعه كبيره من
العملات النادره جدا جدا
اسلاميه والتي كانت خاصه بالثورات
الاسلاميه اللي في العصر العباسي مثلا او
في العصر الاموي كما يوجد درهم نادر جدا
جدا لثوره
عبد الرحمن بن الاشعث اللي ضرب في الكوفه
سنه 82 هجري في فتره عبد الملك بن مروان
وكان هذا الدرهم غريب جدا وكان يعتبر من
النوادر التي يعني لا تتكرر وهو طبعا
يعتبر لقطع الوحيده في العالم في في متحف
الدين الاسلامي كذلك يوجد قطعه لثوره
العلويين اللي هم كانوا في المدينه
الدرهم خاص بمحمد النفس الزكيه ضربوا في
المدينه سنه 145 هجري وهذا الدرهم طبعا
ضرب بالمدينه ويعتبر نادر وفريد من نوعه
على مستوى العالم وموجوده الحمد لله بفضل
الله في متحف الدينار الاسلامي
[موسيقى]
طبعا المتحف هذا يعني يعتبر يعني
يعني
وليف الروح كما يقولون يعني كيف يعني انا
مثلا عندما اكون يعني في حاله انفراد اجي
الى المتحف هذا واجلس بين العملاق وبين
الاسلحه وبين السيوف ايش حياه ثانيه تماما
واشعر باني في عبق التاريخ طبعا يعني هذا
المتحف يعتبر بالنسبه لي هو صديقي هو اخ
لي لاني انا اجلس بين الاشياء هذه
وادارسها واجلس اقراها واعيد وانسخ فيها
واكتب فيها وطبعا اجدد معلوماتي كله بين
فتره وفتره وطبعا شيء يريحني وهو يعتبر
راحتي
[موسيقى]